let's go next to our caller from the
five-seven one area code who's calling
today from 571 hey Mark what's up I had
a question about the reason Hilary
Spears against Bernie Sanders yes so I
was wondering if there would be like him
backlash response from Bernie supporters
in what sense what would they do as far
as a backlash I mean Hillary's not on
the ballot well in the sense that it
would energize and galvanize the Bernie
base so the other thing with Trump right
where the media smears actually worked
in his favor do you think a similar
thing would happen with progressives
it's conceivable but here's the thing at
this point all of these things that just
muddled up the progressive side of the
primary they just helped Biden like he
okay so there's a backlash and the
Bernie supporters are reinvigorated
unless Bernie can take the lead and
start winning primaries soon because
we're only two weeks away from the first
primaries all of this stuff just keeps
Biden and quietly in the lead he'll
start to win primaries and accumulate
delegates so yes there could be a
backlash but it's got to happen now mark
you've gone completely underwater so I'm
gonna let you go something about your
connection is is abhorrent and I don't
know if it's device based or signal
based or whatever the case may be let's
see if we can talk to our caller from
the nine one two area code caller from
nine one two who's this and what's your
question today hi Jonathan
also from Georgia right answer other
torture callers yes I'm a big Andrew
yang fan and I know you've covered yang
throughout this whole yang media
blackout that's been going on recently
my question is your stance our opinion
on his idea of taxing automation to fund
the freedom dividend do you think that
that's gonna hold back or in in any way
interfere with the automation ways that
he thinks
can I have that he thinks is gonna
happen well so a couple things number
one is there a yang media blackout I
know he wasn't at the debate but I'm
seeing him everywhere it's like he's on
he's on network television he's on cable
television he's on the view his wife is
doing all sorts of interviews I don't
know that there is a yang media blackout
I think he just didn't make the last
debate I think before the debate I think
the big thing is the debate not being
there really gave him a lot of push with
the media I've gotten him a few more
calls because was a big deal of him when
the polling and and not being able to
make the stage you know other people who
I believe poll less but somehow still
got up there but feel like it's gotten
him a lot more media attention now but
for a while there was a good bit of
media black I guess it is raising a
little bit I am seeing a little bit a
few more interviews he's doing and more
appearances on media but yeah I feel
like for a while there was a blackout
but I guess you could say yes that's
slowly lifting as his wife is now going
on places and so is he you know a guy
named networks so here's my taxing
automation here's the thing so if we
think back to when cars came into
development and people started saying
hey we've got to slow down this car
stuff because the horse buggy drivers
and the farriers and everybody who works
around horses are going to lose their
jobs it seems crazy to think that just
taxing cars back then would have
prevented cars from being developed and
it also seems crazy to think we would
have wanted that because of course cars
have completely revolutionized how
humans operate so I don't think that you
are going to be able to use a tax to
prevent automation from appearing more
and more in places where it's going to
appear I think eventually it's going to
happen in places that are going to
benefit companies and industries that
will benefit from automation and
remember automation will also benefit
safety in many cases it'll benefit few
minute health there's lots of ways in
which automation will be good I don't
think you're gonna hold it back with
attacks however I am NOT against in the
short to medium term using that tax to
fund retraining and development of new
industries in areas where machines can't
do the work okay so you don't think of
freedom given is the best answer you
think training is because I know he's
talked a lot about that and the freedom
fine talk I'm
a universal basic income is a great idea
and I'm fine
talking about it I just don't know that
I have a super strong position on I
would use an automation tax to fund the
freedom dividend you can fund the
freedom dividend a whole bunch of
different ways I'm not super married to
one way or the other but I am interested
in the idea of taxing to prevent
automation from taking hold
I don't think long term that's going to
work all right thank you all right
appreciate the phone call so much sorry
I don't have time for more people but we
will take calls on the Friday show we
will take a quick break and be back with
plenty more right after this